bonjour berges bernard schmitt merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur arte france la proposition de
réécriture du droit maritime
international d'un côté chantage
contraire au droit de la mer de l'autre
qui est dans son droit et jusqu'où
peuvent aller ses invectives entre paris
et londres
alors clairement les remet en tout mode
mission qui consisterait à avaliser des
refoulements en haute mer ou sur la
manche sont illégales à deux égards
d'abord concernant effectivement le
droit maritime il ya un certain nombre
de conventions internationales qui
régissent le droit maritime notamment la
convention de rome qui nous intéresse
bref le refoulement hauteur date a dit
pour la simple raison qu'elle comporte
de risques bah les listes naufragés de
disparition en mer à la je sais que le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson avait dit hier au journal
l'hôtel de telegraaf et que ça ne sera
pas ne sera c'est que dans certaines
circonstances il est bas taux sont
stables et relativement grand toujours
est il que ça restera pratique pour et
dangereuses surtout la mosquée connu
aussi pour être relativement turbulente
parce qu'il ya des vents autrement dit
toute pratique qui risquait de mettre en
danger des vies humaines et est illégal
il faut d'abord trouver et ensuite nous
poser la question du statut juridique
des personnes une fois est que la vie
est hors de danger ceci tout le volet
droit maritime sur le volet droits des
migrants alors tant que tant que le
royaume uni est soumis aux règles du
conseil de l'europe je dis bien du
conseil de l'europe parce que le conseil
de l'europe n'est pas l'union européenne
le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne au 1er janvier mais il n'a
pas quitté le conseil de l'europe la
crise et l'europe c'est plus large la
russie la turquie lors hermine et
d'autres pays font partie sans être
adhérents à l'union européenne donc tant
que la lose my home ni soumis aux règles
du conseil de l'europe et donc à la
convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales abréger ses audaces
commencé européenne des droits de
l'homme
qui est qui s'impliquent dans le cadre
du conseil de l'europe
un tel refoulement à toul et en anglais
pouces beck est aussi anti conventionnel
donc contre le doigt dans la mesure où
il ya plusieurs décisions de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à
strasbourg qui est le gardien de cette
convention l'acier dh et qui déclare
depuis 2011 à l'époque j'étais deux
décisions qui concernaient la belgique
et la grèce qui depuis 2011 jusqu'à
cette année a décidé à plusieurs fois
que les push back donc les refoulements
en poupe en mer sont illégales dans la
mesure il faut d'abord instruire une
éventuelle demande de protection
internationale donc une demande d'asile
avant de pouvoir décider du renvoi
éventuel vers un pays tiers ou vers le
pays d'origine de la personne ne va me
dire courra le royaume uni n'est pas
dans son droit alors un nom que les deux
volets clairement pas c'est une position
politique mais c'est une décision
doublement
juridiquement illégal est illégal parce
qu'outre la loi avec les conventions
internationales
d'autant plus qu'il risque de mettre en
danger des vies humaines donc là c'est
une question des droits de l'homme a
avant tout oui tout à fait alors qu une
personne qui se trouve en haute mer
c'est d'abord la question du sauvetage
de enter 22e temps quand la personne est
sauvé et donc arrive sur terre ferme
occurrence l des îles britanniques se
pose la question d'une éventuelle
demande de protection internationale
donc de demandes d'asile qui doit être
traitée effectivement juridiquement
pendant trois 3 issues sont possibles
premièrement cette demande est fondée et
doit être traitée par le royaume uni
edouard la moutte déboucher sur une de
protection internationale d'action
statut de réfugié ou une autre
protection et protection subsidiaire
deuxième possibilité
la demande est infondée donc
juridiquement le royaume uni pourrait
envisager le renvoi de la personne vers
son pays d'origine si elle n'est pas
titulaire d'un droit à protection
internationale toiser possibilité la
demande est fondée mais elle n'est qu'
responsable du traitement de cette
demande
ainsi le royaume uni pourrait renvoyer
la personne vers un pays tiers du
continent européen par exemple mais
cette question ne se pose une fois que
les deux premiers stades ont été
traversés donc d'abord le sauvetage de
la vie humaine qui tout est menacé en
mer deuxièmement la possibilité que
doivent à la personne de réclamer la
protection internationale au royaume uni
dès que le troisième stade de décider
que ce besoin n'existe pas ou n'existe
pas un royaume uni parce que trop
section de déjà été obtenus dans un
autre pays et bernard schmitt rapidement
s'il n'y avait pas eu le bac dit est ce
que ce débat aurait eu autant
d'importance
oui et non oui parce que le débat sur le
traitement des migrants cherchant des
migrants et réfugiés cherchant à
rejoindre le royaume uni depuis les
côtes françaises le littoral du nord de
la france existait bien avant nous
rappelons qu'en 2002 il ya cinq ans
instruit par la croix rouge à sangatte
cela coûte de la mort ce qui est fermé
toutes les villes a été instauré à la
fin des années 90 il a été fermé en 2002
ensuite il ya eu les différents
campement à calais notamment là qu'on a
tous les la jungle qui était il ya cinq
ans mais aujourd'hui encore il ya un
certain nombre de migrants qui
s'installe seul à côte le littoral et
qui cherche à joindre le royaume uni aux
différentes raisons 1 que ce soit que c
est des personnes originaires de pays
anciennement colonisés par le royaume
uni et qui ont déjà des communautés des
proches installés au royaume uni que ce
soit parce que cette instance ne pas
pouvoir avoir la protection
internationale qu'elle recherche en
france ou pas d'autre motif qu longtemps
conseil de cette personne parfois on les
oriente va être sérieux d'asile en
france il y avait les accords du touquet
un conclure 2004 à l'époque entre les
premiers à pas les premiers ministres
mais le ministre de l'intérieur
respectifs français britannique nicolas
sarkozy côté français qui est une liste
de l'internet en cas d'échec ce show
ministre l'intérieur le tournis blair
qui accord du touquet qui consistait
pour la france a contrôlé le passage se
sont dit orale cela avance donc cette
question se trouve déjà à l'époque mais
les accords disait à la france vous
devez de traiter et le sort de sept
personnes sur votre sol et notamment
instruit les demandes asus eee ces
casses hommes sont à la recherche de
quelque chose qu'ils accolent
n'autorisait pas à vous foulez haute mer
alors ces accords n'a pas été dénoncé la
question se pose évidemment dans la
mesure des autorités françaises avaient
annoncé que les accords tour est mis en
cause le royaume uni quitté l'union
européenne toujours est il que c'était
pour sa politique dans la mesure où les
accords du touquet sont des accords
bilatéraux est pas d accord dans le
cadre de l'union européenne la question
la question est en tiennent mais la
réponse que vous prétendez jamais abordé
à noël nous réunit six aces police elle
est aussi choquant que ce soit sur le
plan juridique ou autrement sans humain
merci bernard schmitt d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris et
spécialiste du droit des étrangers